the Joe Rogan experience it's amazing
what people can do when they decide
they're gonna do it yes yes but yeah I
mean I think with for for this
particular run you know I probably would
have kept punting it down the road in
you know how to not talk to Justin Wren
to be honest with you like you know when
you do something like that like part of
the reason I think you do that is for me
anyway is when I see like endurance
ultra endurance sport too it can be a
very selfish sport because you're you
know you're putting in tons of training
race day is like an all-day effort with
tons of people helping you out like
they're taking time out of their
schedule their day to come out their
crew pace essentially like be your peer
support system while you're out there
kind of trying to you know do all these
things so you know part of it is like I
want to try to give back in a way as
well as opposed to just always going out
and racing for my own my own sake and
what will be done how will it the will
you have sponsors like yeah I'm gonna do
it hopefully what we'll do is I was
talking to Justin we sponsor you
absolutely I really yeah yeah we wear
like a jheri logo and one of your shirts
or something no doubt about it yeah all
right do it
awesome we got we got one sponsor on
board here we go yeah hell yeah but yeah
so like when I talked to Justin I mean
Justin is I mean you know Justin while
he's been on the show that guy and I
think it was on here that I heard his
podcast for the first time I know I
heard him tell I guess what you would
call his origin story here and I think I
heard it again on like the mind pump
media guy's podcast and it's when I
described just listening to Justin wrens
podcast or his interviews to people I
try to say like well it kind of comes in
these stages where he tells his
background story of like his experience
with bullying and at first you just your
heart just sinks for the guy you're
thinking like well how could anyone have
to go through that I would never want
him to go through that and you kind of
transition into this phase of like you
kind of get nervous and anxious because
you're thinking like well who did I say
something mean to when I was younger or
who did I who did I potentially affect
in a negative way and then it's like
then you just want to try to do
something to support and you know it's
really when you look at someone like
Justin Ren it's it's mind-boggling to me
that
this guy isn't like an internationally
known hero or leader yet anyway
well he's becoming he's getting big he's
getting big I mean the only thing that's
holding him back keeps getting sick yeah
well and that's just [ __ ] crazy
you know he's parasites he's right now
they know what they are yeah I picked up
some parasites in the Congo they can't
even identify them specifically uh-huh
and it's he's really suffering
and you would never know talking to him
like he just goes about it like the
guy's gotten malaya like most people
would probably say okay I went over to
Africa
I got malaria I helped some people out
I'm good I'm good now someone will raise
some money for this charity and we'll
send it over to him or something I know
he keeps going back and keeps getting a
malaria three times yeah parasite so
like when I think of like what we I
think maybe like I mean Justin Wren is
like next-level when it comes to like a
leader I think and I think in the
current especially in the current
climate like you know our leaders today
tend to be you know people like
celebrities athletes and then
politicians and things like that and
it's like I you look around and it can
be very underwhelming about just like
you know some of like like how badly are
like how badly are people actually
trying to help people and how how much
how many of these like politicians
actually care about poor people how many
of them actually care about someone
who's disenfranchised or how much did
how many are they doing it you're doing
it just get elected right did they
actually care Justin it's just care yes
it's all Harrison there's no worry at
all about ulterior motives they don't
exist there's no ulterior motive to
sleep on a dirt floor in a grass shack
with the pygmies like he's done for
months at a time there's he's just doing
it for love yeah yeah so I think like
when when when I look at like I think
people want to help and I think people
want to do things that are good for
Humanity but oftentimes they don't
necessarily have that example to kind of
like to lead the way then they look into
a void in some cases and I think Justin
is the type of person who you know if
the more people we can get to know about
him his story and what he's trying to do
on the the wells and the farms and with
the pygmy as well as this new branch on
anti-bullying
the better so when I reached out to him
I was actually like kind of surprised
like I shot him a note on I think
Instagram and Twitter and I thought look
he's probably not gonna see it cuz he's
not following me and he responded in
like less than a couple hours like you
followed me responded back and he's just
like this is so awesome I feel super
honored that you'd wanna you know help
out in some way it's like he's just
always looking for opportunities to help
promote this great cause so then you
know when I got that response from him
it was like clarification of what I
think I some I already knew about the
guy just from listening to him on your
show and others that you know he's
really in this for a big reason and if
if we need a fast track this
cross-country event to bring him some
some awareness well we'll see what we
can do but he's in everything he does he
does to help and promote other people
even when I was trying to talk to him
about his parasite
I had a key didn't want to ya get him on
track he's like you got to interview my
doctor and know what's going on man
what's happening with you because I
worry about the guy because yeah he's so
selfless when he's talking about like
blacking out and all these like like
after training they got to get him in
the shower because he's shivering he's
pale white and like bro what is going on
with you like what is this he's like oh
you got to meet my doctor he's amazing
like stop stop with the [ __ ] doctor
I couldn't want to get what is happening
he doesn't want to talk about himself
right it's amazing the most selfless
person I've ever ever talked he's
talking about fighting again right he's
getting over these incredible bouts of
antibiotics that you know weaken your
ligaments right like when you take cipro
or any of these like super intense
antibiotics one of the side effects is a
lot of times people get injured like
your ligaments get injured because
apparently there's a weakening effect
which is really kind of it's really
fascinating when you think about the
human body as an overall organism and
that it's really an ecosystem and that
when you flood antibiotics into that
ecosystem to try to prevent disease from
destroying it you also have these
unintended side effects and one of them
is weakened ligaments and there's a lot
of correlation between people getting
staph infection
then blowing out knees a cl's you know
tendons and things along those lines
afterwards so he both of his shoulders
are [ __ ] you know and this is post
antibiotics and yet he's still talking
about fighting so you can bring more
awareness to the pygmies I'm like bro
please stop
just get your shoulders fixed yeah
whatever you got going on let's let's
heal that up first and then also find
out what the [ __ ] this parasite is that
you don't even know what this didn't
even know that says he's not even
thinking about himself is like if I can
get in and get a fight in by the end of
the year I'm at the end of the year man
it's [ __ ] December like stop it
you're not getting in by the end of the
year you're not getting in the beginning
of 2020 let's heal up heal up we gotta
want you healthy yeah a rare totally
selfless person and he saw such a
powerful force for good for those
peoples the people that live in the
Congo and what he's done for them I mean
I don't know how many wells they've
built so far but they made an alliance
with the cash app which is one of my
sponsors so every time someone downloads
the cash app when they use the code Joe
Rogan whether it's for Google for
Android or for I for an iPhone for Apple
you get $10 goes to this cause so
they've raised hundreds of thousands of
dollars and they're building wells right
now it's just this amazing thing that
he's done and he's just like you feel
like a piece of [ __ ] like when you're
around annoyed why am I not just nice
he's so nice it's it's like it was
enough for him to find people who were
hard off you had to go and find the most
forgotten most hard off that's right
there's like so many people in Africa
have it robbed you know who's got the
roughest yeah yeah that live and you
know and on top of that the guy's a
world-class mixed martial artist he
really is he's one of the best
heavyweights in the world and how much
better would he be if he was selfish and
they spent all of his time training and
not getting malaria three times not
having this unknown parasite that they
think might be in his [ __ ] brain I
mean they don't even know what I was
just reading this story about some guy
who was having seizures and it turns out
he had all these worms in his brain and
I'm like and I was thinking about Justin
I'm it was from uncooked pork from this
ah and Justin they think
the problem with the Congo is it's so
remote and you don't get a lot of people
to go there and get diseases and then
come back so they might not even know
what this is might be something that no
one's ever got before sure and then made
it back to Western civilization to be
examined yeah Wow yeah Wow what the hell
man yeah and you would never know
talking to you know you just doesn't
want to talk about it yeah let's talk
about his friend hey you got to get my
friend on the podcast he's really sweet
it's a great guy he makes makes kites
like once each kite is gonna generate X
amount of dollars from a bottle up
Justin red and feed it to everyone I
guess well you know it's an interesting
I'm not just an interesting it's a it's
a beautiful sort of expression of what
can happen to a person when they
experience deep pain and sadness and
then they find a way out and then they
find a way to help other people and
that's sort of what he's done you know
his childhood was really rough and he
came out of that a super kind person as
opposed to being angry and mean I mean
this is what we need more in the world
right we need more people building
people up and helping and less people
tearing people down and then hating
means so much of so much of what social
media is used for and so much of what
the internet is used for is hate his
anger there's so much anger you know and
to see someone like Justin this rare
soul that has found a way to almost
universe I mean like everything he does
is channeled towards good all of it you
know including kicking people's asses
yeah which is like how do you make that
good you found it found a way to make
kicking people's asses a good thing it's
beautiful I'm really honored to be his
friend say he's one of my you know
they're the rarest people that I know
yeah no doubt no I'd say it's been cool
to hear his story and you know I think
thanks to you he's probably got a much
bigger audience too so
[Applause]